it's been a whole year since i last made
a myth busting video but now it's time
to return with 69 myths and dumb science
ideas for season two we've got a lot to
get through so uh let's crack on here's
my creator code just in case you want to
use it ding myth one in the trailer for
the new season a character is seen
sliding under a tank to plant c4 is
sliding under a tank actually possible
well here we go and no no it isn't
unless penny is just too thick for this
task i don't think it's possible yet
once this happened i slid underneath and
the tank became stuck on penny myth
busted maybe that gap is too small what
about sliding underneath vehicles with
those chunky tyres uh nope and what
about chunky tires on a truck
yes that does work this is weird
speaking of sliding into position what
about sliding under all the io haulage
rigs yeah easy enough but for some
reason it's not all of them some of them
will completely stop you in your sliding
tracks when driving a tank there's a
small hole to see the driver can we
snipe someone through that tiny hole
well let's go it's another bust the shot
lands but only acts to break the cover
of the driver myth the repair tool can
fix anything that's metal that can't be
true can it here's a damaged arcade
cabinet keep an eye on those cracks and
holy heck it's true this tool reverses
time on anything metal myth the cow
catcher will resize to fit the vehicle
okay so if i throw this cow catcher on
this bigger vehicle they should oh they
do confirmed the cow catcher resizes to
suit the vehicle how about a cow catcher
on an ice cream truck um no and on a
tank of course not it's a tank what
happens when two vehicles with cow
catchers plow into each other this is
gonna be good three two one go
absolute carnage and just in case you're
wondering what happens when two cars
normally collide this happens
next what happens when two tanks go head
to head we'll check this both fall on
their backs like turtles stuck on their
shells oh and this leads to another myth
can we flip a tank yes we can without a
doubt this is my favorite thing this
season what happens when a repair tool
is used on a broken down car
look at this it reverses time and even
brings back the tires oh let's take this
further what if the tires on the car
were chunky to begin with will they come
back as big yes they do this is great
this thing is magical this led to
another myth can we hide c4 inside a
broken vehicle and then repair it so
it's hidden inside so for this one i
smashed the windscreen threw in some c4
and then we fixed it up good as new you
can still see it but i don't think
anyone would look for it and the moment
of truth can we still explode that c4
and yes we can
that is satisfying this person says c4
can now be picked up by your enemy and
used on you
i didn't believe it until i saw it
myself it's true
as this repair tool is so great can we
use it to repair enemies oh god no i
regret nothing keeping with that c4 can
we hide it inside a tank where the
driver sits this could be complicated we
managed to get this to work we added c4
into the cockpit and yes indeed when
someone got it it closed up and it was
locked inside but when we clicked to
explode it the driver didn't take any
damage at all all that happened was the
same as the sniper earlier on the yellow
part became disabled so technically myth
busted so mantling was brought into
fortnite so let's quickly go over those
mechanics can we mantel a one-tile wall
doing a standing jump well yeah quite
simple what about 1.3 tiles high it's
it's possible yeah standing jump can
clear up to 1.3 tiles how about one and
a half tiles high this is possible but
you'll need to perfectly time a running
jump to get this by the way if you're
struggling with timing of these mantle
jumps you should know that you can
switch them in the game settings i have
mine set to push forwards which means if
it's possible to mantle my character
will grab hold and the ultimate test can
we mantel two tiles high no of course we
can't why would you even think that
so using all these skills the next myth
is is it possible to mantel all the way
up to the top of the daily bugle without
using any stairs it sure is and there's
even a world record on offer if you want
to do this faster than everybody else
i'll tell you more about that record in
another video coming soon next myth is
it possible to shoot through the rotor
blades on the airships okay this is like
a double one in real games you'll be
heated into the air if you try and stand
on the rotor blades here but in battle
labs it's possible so we'll do it there
and here we go
yes it's technically possible to shoot
through the gaps yet it's not reliable
can the thermal optics spot someone in a
bush well can you see them well they are
there so no no you can't you can't see
anyone hiding with your thermal vision
can the thermal optics see people under
underwater let's try it and it's another
bust only above the blue stuff although
it is a little easier to see people
swimming underwater here's the best and
most ridiculous myth of the episode is
it possible to stack a tank on a tank to
make a mega tank yes you heard me right
this is my kind of stupid i asked a
bunch of the psg discord to help me out
and they sure did there's a link in the
description if you want to join our
discord by the way and look what we
created this monstrosity it only stays
up if no one touches it it all falls to
pieces the second we start shooting
driving and moving the turrets but i
don't think we wasted an hour of our
life creating this monstrosity it's
beautiful i hear there's seven tanks in
a public game of fortnight one day that
will be a world record we will go for
while we have five tanks let's do
another myth with enough firepower an
airship can be destroyed
we tried for like 10 minutes but no this
ain't going anywhere myth busted
last season fallable trees were added to
fortnite and we discovered a tree will
automatically fall on top of one of your
enemies but we didn't know how it chose
who to squish so we sat in for a game
and one by one we knocked down trees
until we understood what happened it
turns out the tree will always hit an
enemy but it will hit the one closest to
the tree so if you're in a gunfight this
season with no builds and the tree looks
like it's coming down don't be the
closest to the tree because it will hit
you myth a pickaxe can take off
someone's overshield in a single hit
this can't be true can it and no 20
damage as usual you'll need to hit them
three times for them to actually feel it
does a tank float this one seems too
good to be true oh it does it does myth
comfort confer no no it stinks it sinks
just a little later myth busted can a
campfire repair a tank there's not a
chance is there well let's try and um it
sure does fire is magical in fortnite it
can heal us all i wonder if the repair
tool can start a campfire as its fire on
fire and no because fortnite logic
doesn't make any sense can a repair tool
bring back a fully destroyed tank let's
try it let's destroy this tank
does the repair tool bring it back it
does not and eventually the tank will
get so sick of your shizzle it will
vanish into thin air question when
builds return will they stop a tank
tanks are quite big i don't think this
will work but this is an easy myth to
check here are four walls wood brick
metal and armored let's see what the
tank doing
it easily smashes through the first
three walls but the armored wall will
stop it in its tracks for a moment it'll
need to reverse and recommit to take
that wall out at a second try
when using a cow catcher as cover can it
be repaired as quickly as one person
shoots to destroy it ah so kinda is the
best way to put that when building comes
back can a cow catcher be used to break
someone's wall wow yes the cow catcher
is instantly a way to take your wall
away can mantelling be used to stop fall
damage this is really interesting as it
depends from what height but yes it can
be used at lower height to prevent any
fall damage but if you try it from a
crazy height the animation will begin
yet he'll still take all the fall damage
now let's go into the future what
happens when builds come back can we
build a wall and mantel onto it when we
fall here's the setup this fall here
takes 49 health points away but by
building and mantling whilst falling he
takes zero damage at all fortnite is
changing even for the sweats this person
wants to know what glider does the
origin have
and i can confirm he has the default
glider thanks for your help origin is it
possible to mantel trees this one is
good to know if you're ever playing hide
and seek because it's true depending on
which type of tree you try to mantel it
is possible staying up there though
isn't easy but the option's there should
you want it myth a tank can use a player
made bridge this one surprised me
because one it's true completely true
and it also works with simple wooden
structures we can get a tank anywhere we
want with our own builds can a player
survive a tank being dropped on them for
science i became the victim and
no no full-on squashed rip what happens
when a tank uses a rift i'm down to try
this and it sure can but the results
vary on three different occasions i had
three different outcomes sometimes it's
fine the tank will land and you can
drive away sometimes the tank will
become unusable and start sliding on its
own way and sometimes this will happen
you'll be full on glitched under the map
where you're likely insta die which
leads to another useful myth glitching
under the map can reveal future map
changes i know exactly where to look for
this one and tada myth confirmed these
are the rock family which are coming
back to the game over the next few
months if you've watched my content
since chapter one you'll know how
awesome these guys are if not be sure to
tune in next week so there we have it 69
myths chased tested and busted thanks
for sticking around it's been a while
since i've done myth chasing and i've
really enjoyed this i'll be back again
later in the week see ya
[Music]
you